Mexican gang rivalry started over a pair
of shoes yeah next to Mafia Pie Face
Mexican Mafia member gave a pair of
shoes that he stole somebody from a
different area like it was north and
south southern Mexicans and there's
northern Mexico Southern Mexicans are
Mexican Mafia Northern Mexicans or La
Familia Nuestra if they stole a pair of
shoes from one of the Nortenos and he
gave it to one of the leaders of the
Mexican Mafia when the guy saw hey those
were my shoe blah blah robot ended up
and yeah we'll take them then and so he
robot ended up going into there's a
dabbing both him and his cell partner
and that's how that started per pair of
shoes